[Music]
[Music]
this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer mike epstein
return very clearly draws elements from
roguelikes
souls likes metroidvanias action
platformers bullet hell shooters and
horror games but while it borrows from
all those genres
its unique flow ensures that its chaotic
shooting galleries and creepy
storytelling feel decidedly new
returners many moving parts coalesced
into a rare shooter that grabs you with
its mechanics and its story and never
lets go
seducing you with its challenges and a
foreboding sense of dread every step of
the way
when you start returning intestinal
scout celine vassas crash lands on an
alien planet
atropos which is broadcasting a
mysterious signal
stranded celine makes some startling
discoveries on the planet
including the game's titular trait when
she dies celine returns
to the crash site seemingly unharmed
to explain much more would give away too
much you want to know as little about
return
and its story as you can going in yes
return is in the name
which is a not so subtle nod to return
all's run based structure
it falls into the broader definition of
roguelite celine starts each run from
the crash site but holds a few key
upgrades
and one of two in-game currencies from
run to run
everything else including her weapons
artifacts that provide passive upgrades
and consumables like healing items
disappear with each death
celine wanders through the procedurally
arranged and populated landscape of
atropuls hoarding gear
upgrading her health and weapon level
and gunning down the planet's
strange-looking
tentacle-wiggling creatures all of which
want you dead
most of your enemies have the ability to
shoot some kind of bright colorful
projectile
at you in a large combat arena the room
very quickly fills with a gauntlet of
neon orbs and beams of light for you to
sidestep
jump over and dash through each enemy
species has its own bullet type with a
predictable pattern to learn but when
you put four or more
together even the simple enemies can
create complex beautiful light shows
that will put you down if you aren't at
the top of your game
unlike most bullet hell shooters where
you're looking down from overhead
returner puts projectiles in your face
and makes you react quickly and
gracefully
that can be a challenge sometimes the
number of bright beams and orbs on the
screen get so unwieldy that it can feel
impossible to keep up
maternal's combat mechanics reward
players who can perfectly dodge enemy
attacks while keeping their composure
with every kill selene builds up
adrenaline which provides temporary
bonuses like a more powerful melee
attack
and a glowing aura that makes enemies
easier to see so long as you don't take
damage
there's also an active reload mechanic
which helps you dish out as much bullet
hell as you take
given the ridiculous number of bullets
you have to avoid at any given time
it can be tough to work in a quick
reload between dodgers
in fact it pays to know when to skip a
reload rather than risk delaying your
next attack
more importantly it's an easy and very
tangible way to see your skills improve
run to run
celine can find a small but nicely
varied array of guns for herself
as well as artifacts which offer passive
upgrades
her arsenal ranges from classic pistols
and assault rifles to the electro pylon
driver
which fires posts that generate laser
beams between them
allowing you to trap an enemy in a
deadly laser grid each weapon type also
comes with randomly assigned perks which
you unlock by killing enemies and which
persist
across runs as your weapon level grows
the weapons you find have better stats
along with more and better perks and you
always have a sword which lets you
disable enemy shields and can quickly
dispatch enemies who get in close
when you have a strong understanding of
your tools you can find a rhythm for
working any combat scenario that's
specific to your build
not every upgrade is entirely a blessing
many of the items and chess you'll find
will be malignant
so picking up or opening them will incur
a temporary penalty until you complete
an objective
for example you may do half as much
damage with your sword until you use two
consumable items
like a temporary shield or a healing
item you also find
parasites which impose both an upgrade
and a debuff
and can't be switched out without a
special item or a device found in the
world
while you can simply avoid any items
with potential negative impact
it's hard to build up power without them
so the quest to make a winning build
often forces you to make some smart
compromises and occasionally roll the
dice to increase your prowess
this wide range of weapons and gear is
both a blessing and a curse
on the one hand you'll never have to run
the same strategy twice
on the other your successor is largely
contingent on finding the right stuff
this is true in most roguelites to some
degree but it's especially prevalent
here
when you have the right gear you're
unstoppable when you don't
you may struggle to make even
incremental progress
you also have to flex your beam dodging
skills with a fair amount of complex
platforming
many rooms will tempt you with items
guarded by laser grids or long trails of
small platforms
return controls are tight and responsive
so you'll have the tools you need to
navigate even when the timing is
extremely tight
assuming you have the precision and
reflexes to master them having traps
obstacles and hidden rims to find in
every run means the act of exploring
never feels wasted or boring
you're always desperate for more health
or that next upgrade
and even when you come to know the shape
of every prefab room
there's always a sense that you don't
know what might be around the next
corner
though they change with every life each
of return of zones follows a loose basic
structure with a main path
and branching side paths on your first
time through each zone you'll come
across a barrier on the main path that
you can't breach
either because you need a key or a
movement ability you don't have
this will lead you down a secondary main
path that once completed
you will not need to repeat on future
runs the result is a shifting and
changing micro run
to reach the next objective you'll need
to play through the next
two to four hours of the game without
dying to advance the story but you won't
need to complete every step on a winning
run
this creates a balance between the
endurance based challenge of the
traditional roguelite
where you not only need to succeed but
do so well enough that you can continue
on
and the extreme challenge put forth by
the bullet hell style shooting galleries
you have to conquer
it also opens the door for returners
many challenging boss fights which
in typical souls like fashion ask you to
fight giant
daunting enemies that can literally fill
the screen with waves of attacks that
are as beautiful as they are deadly
no matter the challenge progress always
feels attainable removing some of the
sting of the repetitive
unforgiving nature of the run-based
structure moreover
on a narrative level mixing up your
objectives helps create a sort of fog
around
your goals you always know the way
forward but what you're actually doing
changes
over time between the shifting maps and
the ever-changing objectives you're
never quite
sure where you're headed which feels
nerve-wracking that doesn't necessarily
mean you're lost
the way forward is almost always clear
but your lack of awareness fosters a
general sense of confusion that
amplifies this undercurrent of
discomfort that washes over you while
exploring atropus
return is consistently spooky and
occasionally terrifying
you don't get much about celine the
planet or why she's there early on but
the mystery is constantly at the
forefront of your mind
you receive a drip feed of information
from run to run through audio logs
monologues and cutscenes which you find
by exploring the different rooms that
pop up as you make it closer and closer
to your goal
returner uses that lack of information
aggressively
frequently showing you images and
referencing events for which you have
little to no context
all in service of creating a slippery
understanding of celine
a nightmarish impression of atropus and
a mystique around the true nature of
your mission
i know why they became severed to find
punishment
for failing ascension ascension
no sooner has the word escaped my lips
than a vast
image of the transcendent watcher in the
deep below
consumes my mind i have begun having
visions of where i have yet to go
they lead me continually downwards from
olympus and into
myself i alone
am worthy what happened
to her that is not me
the horror of returnal is largely
sequestered to the narrative of the game
but there are a handful of playable
story sequences where it comes through
front and center
from time to time celine will find an
area with her home from earth
a literal american house just sitting in
the middle of the wilderness
when the time is right and she enters
the house you're put into a short first
person sequence that focuses on
narrative and mood
you have no guns no real control of what
to do and you're subjected to some
spooky events that teach you more about
the world
while sending shivers down your spine
this
was taken after i left why
return is constantly unsettling and
consistently challenging
its mysterious story and demanding
action feels intense
urgent and fresh the fast-moving combat
manages to appear incredibly daunting
bordering on overwhelming without
actually ever becoming insurmountable
every moment is a rush either because
you just barely evaded a giant purple
laser
or because you have no idea why there's
an apollo era astronaut following your
every move
do you need to be a little brave to play
return or yeah do you need to be a
glutton for punishment
it helps they say that anything worth
doing should scare you just a little bit
i'm not sure if that's always true but
return makes a strong case for it
i have to try harder